okay welcome everybody this is the
optional title for my talk
personalization TV on ok and radio with
Rowlands and action modeling
my name is halal Georgia Dixon I worked
for illumise
small consultancy and I'm currently with
NRK on the radio team and I'm working on
personalization personalization is
something that cuts between both radio
and TV so there's team from both
products now this is not a one-man thing
we've created
there's product owners leaders there's
UX UI testers application developers etc
so this is just not me there's more
people on this the agenda is sort of why
why we went with an archer system for
this and then we have the some details
on the implementation just to give a
look into that we will look at
operations of how how are we running
something like an actor system on
kubernetes and then there's some lessons
learned during the last year or so
so TV and arcaded I know is the
equivalent of BBC and the iPlayer and so
when you open up the front page what you
get just under the big hero image is my
content your content thanks to you how
much things you have marked as a
favorite things you think that are yours
we are not putting anything else in
there
which you have not you have not acted on
so this is all your content
this is screenshot from the old one so
that was so enormous from the front page
using the new version and this is the my
page so with the old system where we
have the continued watching at the top
and then there were your shows below
that and then the history underneath
another view of these data this is a
documentary nature serious you can see
that I watched two first episodes or
rather my kids have and then they have
our somewhere in the beginning of the
third episode and well the problem with
this the old solution was that people
can really find their content they all
know they had these favorites and and
resumed watching having two different
things that were yours were troubling as
a public broadcaster we have on some
shows fairly short rights because we
don't do the RM so you can often see
that you are watched episode one and
it's probably lost rights before we
publish episode 7 so you sort of need to
keep track with us and then there's this
one and that's a problem and most do
that wrong and we want to do this right
we want to take you to the right place
so what happens if you are on episode 4
and we get rice for episode 5 should we
notice you should be put that content
further up this green on the cellphone
or on the smart TV it's not room for
that many items so you want to make sure
that the items we show you when your
content is relevant depending on where
you are as an individual not not that
okay we got you season perhaps
interesting for a lot of people but it's
really what we want to try to hit is is
if relevant where you are and and so
that is one thing for sequential content
but then we have other types of serious
we have news shows if you're on
I watched Saturday's so seven days ago
the next episode I want to watch is that
six days ago or is it today's episode
that is also something we need to solve
and then to do this when you have a
small you port we wanted to be dynamic
to change the content it's still yours
and we wanted to sort of be active if we
get rights we want to perhaps put it up
if you're losing rights in six states
and you're halfway into an episode we
want to put that one up to make sure
that you get the chance to watch it
before we take it away so now it's one
reason what needed or wanted to build a
new system or do something about it and
then we had the old architecture where
we had a Web API we had a redis document
storage we loaded once you logged in we
loaded your data into Redis and well
that works fine if you have enough Redis
instances and we run in a sure we're
ready is not the cheapest product they
have and and we're doing Lua script on
Redis so means that Redis is single
threaded so if we have an expensive Lua
script everything is slow unless we had
enough Redis instances and when we made
this back in 2014 15 things look like
this this is also called a big ball of
mud the red ones are circular
dependencies between namespace yay
that sounds like fun and then we were
slightly moving into micro service
bounded context trying to split our
domain based on functionality and that
so made it easier for us to start reason
about how they should work and we sort
of decided okay we want to do something
about personalization and then we have a
rule if you're doing something big
something that needs a decision you
present at least three options and it
should be presented as by the team or I
by one person it's not that I present
for a new present when we go and then
you get why this is might my system your
solution kind of battle they want to
sort of present three equal options in
this case we ended up with sort of
looking at five okay we go to old way
we'd read it and see if that could work
and we were fairly certain that we
didn't want it we was one of the most
expensive components we had in Russia
stack sequel yeah
probably but that would be as a view
model that we need something else to
drive our domain because the domain
logic when you start looking at asking
for sorting for a lot of programs for a
lot of users and you want to sort of hit
you with six seven eight business rules
and you have to evaluate the content
evaluate where they are evaluate if the
next episode is available is and so
forth writing that query was not very
fun even though we tried and then we
looked at cosmos DB in graphic yeah for
some of this graphic bag could be very
nice to see okay people have watched
this I've also watched this and and you
can sort of navigate that one and then
actually modeling was something we
looked at it felt that perhaps if if
each user is an actor we get to sort of
sort and deal with content for that user
individually that could perhaps fit we
also get actual functions better and are
we making an accurate system in
functions there was no durable functions
at that time and it's sort of clicked
when we came to the utilization that a
favorite might be able to sort itself if
it gets enough input it can do it fairly
easy and then we can have six to seven
method calls each M implementing a
single business rule so we evaluate one
business rule at the time based on some
event instead of trying to evaluate all
business rules when they're sorting it
yeah and that left us with these three
these are probably the most the famous
actor systems on net you have a cadet
net we have people in using a chi in n
RK and then we have proto actor we
discarded that fairly quick the
documentation was not there at the time
we felt that the updates in gita were
not quite as frequent as we would like
it especially lack of documentation in
c-sharp was not encouraging and then
orleans we could most likely implement
to this in a card on that as well but we
like the orleans virtual actor paradigm
where you don't control the life cycle
you don't sort of i don't have to
explicitly go and create and have a
three and hierarchy of actors I sort of
just asked from an actor and that is
because we have a catalogue of about one
and a half two million programs when you
look at TV and radio and if I could just
ask for it without knowing if it existed
or not and just get it if it was there
fine so we felt that the the model was
was in Orleans suited us so Orleans
consists of to think there's a runtime
and a programming paradigm sort of a
model you work with and and runtime are
called zeros and then you have Grange
which is what your program around which
is the sort of the fundamental building
block there's a talk by Reuben bond
works with Orleans where this is from
which is a nice introduction to Orleans
so
grain is a virtual actor they always
exist or they just exist up here when
you need them and you don't really
deactivate them the life cycle is
controlled by aliens and and sort of and
you don't use it anymore you don't use
it it's a effective distributed object
you just have an instance is running on
some side of some server somewhere and
it's a sort of a unit of computation
implementation of the the interface and
state and they communicate by sending
and receiving messages just like other
actors and then they react incoming
messages and unless you do something
special and you wanted to do something
special they do one thing at a time it's
just very comfortable very easy to
reason about
they often represent objects in a domain
as I said when we just first started
thinking about it we thought perhaps
they'd use it would be an actor and that
would be it and it would have the user
would have favourites and whatever
history but then we sort of realized
pretty soon that that would be too big
of an actor so so a sort of big thing
when you start working and having fun
with this is to select the right
granularity get the right size of them
so now if you are watch the show that
position in that show would for you
would be one actor if you have a
favorite that would be one actor as well
yeah so a green it has an identity
that's how you sort of interact with it
you need to have the key to the actor to
interact with you cannot say give me all
of Harold's favorites unless you have
some way of doing that so you have to
sort of build that yourself and then
there's behavior which is sort of the
implementation of the class and then
there's a optional state that may be
just existing in memory for the time you
have the actor alive or it may be
persisted in some storage
and you sort of define one here I say I
have a user it's has a string key you
can send the message from a sender with
a body and you can list all the messages
are that actor has so a little rapping
problem but there's the implementation
this state is injected by the system so
you have a grain state from the store
messages which is a list of messages and
then you can send a message there's a
regular async/await
pattern nothing special easy to reason
about this as well I think and you use
it by calling get grain and what you
actually get is a proxy more or less an
implementation of that interface you can
call it from the client and then you can
list the contents so so this looks like
normal code what happens is that this my
run-on I took completely different
server so you have to be little bit
aware that when you interact with these
grains there is a possible network
latency and so on and then so what we
really think of it is this sort of you
have a bunch of instances running
somewhere in your owner cluster and you
work with them
so how do you model for this when we
started modeling we we looked at the
access pattern for our API how well we
our API use this and that's again you
cannot query except by the ID of a grain
so that so it makes it important to
match it with your with your API surface
so we looked at our documentation sort
of which user event which system events
or domain events do we have and the ones
we will look at our Markus favorite
delete favorite you can list all the
favorites and then there's a case where
we wanna enrich another view where we
don't really have a list to work from
but we get a lot of show IDs and we need
to sort of look up is this a favorite or
not positions as well we set a position
you can delete a position and or resume
watching you can list them as well and a
if you have watched enough of a show we
might want to turn it into a favorite
for you that leaves us with one decision
based on the limitations in indexing of
actors do we want to read from the actor
model or and use it dashing well as an
active cache aleene's color patterns
mouth cache which is the action model is
your domain model and persistence is
just something that happens
or should we sort of use our actors as a
domain model but then create a view
model based on all the state changes
like Morsi Korres pattern so we could
have those queries where we want to
select some say get all favorites for
Harold Skipton continue well we we
wanted the caching so we decided okay
let's go with trying to use the action
model that's nice nicely modeling and
not have a separate read model and we
sort of split it okay we have catalog
and this is this is outside data this is
a cache of data from our other systems
and we want to have that close to our
own data and we wanted to make sure that
we are up even if the other system is
down so this is Sam Newman talks about
this Microsoft's book and also the
inside-outside data paper by Pat Helen
touches on this and then you have sort
of the favourites to you that okay we
have favorite thing in position as well
let's look at details so the catalog we
have multiple sources for content you
have podcast we have TV series we have
live radio etc and some of them use
various ID schemes and we did not want
to deal with that so we sort of decided
fairly quickly on let's just map
everything into our own IDs we take an
external idea map it into a good so we
deal with only dudes down at Catholic
item and then there's the catalog item
which can be a podcast or a serious
episode or movie like a single program
now these are things that are used by
across all users across all Serene's
instances and then there's a concept
called stateless which means that
there's a grain normally a grain can
only be activated on one server at a
time so it's running on one one silo and
the silos know where it's on so they
have a grain reference and they look it
up and say ok this one is running on
this server so if you want this one go
over there but then you have these
stateless ones which can run on multiple
servers in the cluster and you can also
allow them to run
have multiple instances on a server if
it's something with high throughput but
these are we have one of these stateless
grades run on each of our silos and they
are backed so they when they load up
they load this state from the state
phone once we have and this gives us the
throughput we need when a lot of users
are working with looking at the same
show sort of you have some popular shows
and you know that okay so they're coming
there's a big thing everyone you know it
watches so that's that's an important
concept to have and then we have
favorites so we we sort of list
favorites from the API that means that
we we needed a to have an order on them
and a list of them and to not load
everything
when a user hits us we'd thought okay
the API is page the clients date doesn't
really make sense to display a hundred
items or thousand items in the cell
phone so they want they they are paging
anyway the clients so let's just follow
that and page it ourselves as well so a
page has a from and to rank the user
favorites has list of pages and they're
ranked starting in and rank and then
when you user hits us it will normally
load just the first page we don't have
to load all the data for user and then
it ended up in a favorite so well call
to list favorites maybe an instance of
the use of Harry's crane an instance of
the favorite page crane and then one
instance for each of user fairies will
loaded and it's so really nicely and
fast
and then we have position more of the
same except that we also group position
by series we need to look up all the
positions within a season so we so we
need to keep track of that as well and
then we make a grain for it to keep
track of that we can have seasons with
800 episodes in them used in hourly news
and radio
so so we paging is absolutely necessary
and once we change something here it
will sort itself and update the pages
and keep track of that
another thing is nice is that we don't
you have the persisted state but we also
have state which is not persisted which
is just in memory when we load it up so
for instance when you're watching
something the clients report to us every
30 second which means that the last
program episode you've watched will be
the same from when once you start
watching something and that means that
we don't have to restart it if the use
of positions no your last what you
watched last the time so some things we
can just keep in memory while other
thing are persisted in state and then
also this one doesn't really know about
rules for favorites but the nice thing
here is that the program episode
position can message our favorite and
the favorit will then decide ok are we
and within the business rules for
creating a favorite of it if you have
sort of if you skipping in a program or
and you've not really watched anything
of it should we make it a favorite
probably not you're not interested if
you just watch two minutes yeah so
there's gives us very nice details on
how to implement the the business rules
for it and we feel that working with
actors and the main modeling and
matching it we
the language our model is originally in
Norwegian our businesspeople
Thaksin region our UX people Thaksin
region so having a action model
innovation enables us to talk to them
about the model they can actually
understand it when I say I use a
favorite or a page or something they can
relate to it which I if I mention a
index on shows and Redis they would like
index what he's talking about
what's the heart set but this is
something they can relate to and then we
have the problem of enriching all the
views as I said Orleans is a virtual
actor model so if you if you ask for a
grain for an ID it will be created but
when we are to enrich a search result
let's say you search for something and
we want to mark everything on that
searches with a star we have to actually
go and check because we don't know if
the grain exists or not I mean we check
the grain gets initialized and gets the
state so to avoid that we we ended up
using something called a bloom filter
it's a probabilistic data structure
where you can sort of verify if
something is in a set or not so what
happens is that you hash something with
let's say you hush it twice with
different seeds so you get two values
you have a bit array so if I hash this
boot and I get 26 and 46 I mark bit 26
and 46 and that array so when I want to
look it up okay I hash it all these two
bits mark if not I'm not going to love
the grain if it is a loaded grain and
that makes it quite cheap to check large
sets for my content
so state state in Orleans can be
provided by a number of sources comes
built in with table storage is probably
the most common one you can do in memory
of course noise for testing but it
supports Cassandra dynamodb I know some
guys who implemented bigquery to power
it now we are mostly using table storage
we used cosmos but find that table
storage is sufficient fast enough if we
do some spreading of data and very cheap
[Music]
since we are some working with the
system are you living system various
when you deploy you can have various
versions running at the same time you
need to think about worsening of states
and here's a part where I think that
having our model and our code in F sharp
is really good because it makes it
extremely easy with discriminated unions
so this is our ID mapper green it has a
state detail which is just a bank for
what we call a version state and the
version state is in the middle there so
it's either a version one of good or
it's the worsen two of macrostate detail
version two and there worsen to as these
properties and then there's a default
for it so we can extend this without
breaking anything we can add the worst
of three everything will run and that's
what you have to do when we if you want
to deploy a new version we add verse and
three and we convert that to version two
so all clients understand version 3 and
knows that there's one knows what to do
with it and then we're ready we
implement the conversion for it and
starts running worse than 3 so this is
what we do with when we get a detail in
we sort of use a pattern matching see ok
we're
one if it doesn't have a good well I
made my luck like this and then if it
does have a good we know it's mapped
beforehand we call it true and sort of
okay if it's a version - it's a person -
so don't do anything so having having a
good type system really helped us there
and think if you are going to work with
actors and persisting state this is
something to think about how will your
worsen it if you need to upgrade your
grains how will you do that yeah another
thing while we're on the model is that
since we are using our actors as an sort
of active model we're reading and
writing through it that makes etag and
caching extremely simple when you load
the grain from the database they already
have at any time it's a little bit hard
to reach but you can always add our own
view it in memory because we know every
time we write a grain you do it in a
controlled manner and you can then
update it so this is a really nice side
effect and a really good way to offload
quite a few of the queries from the
clients if you want to another thing is
reporting since we are doing these
grains where you don't query them just
access them by ID doing some counters
etc means that you have to think about
it beforehand unless you have a storage
where you can do analytics on it or
something
so what you say a common pattern is to
sort of have grains that aggregate data
for you and so what we do is that we
count users become favorites you count
the positions how much people have
watched and then we a great the that in
stateless grains we just keep the state
in memory and on each silo
in our cluster we sort of do a subtotal
and and we have one stateful grain which
is responsible for storing it in the
database as well as emitting the data
we're pushing it to metrics as in
application insights
I've seen people pushing it with single
R and getting real-time insights into
the system and also as we see later on
the dashboard for Orleans is powered by
grains as well doing this kind of thing
so operations so we have this system
running and you want to have silos
running all the time controlled and that
fits fairly well with kubernetes so we
build docker images in teamcity we push
it up with octopus deploy and in our
system you have ended up with for the
images one for the client API that is
going away or has gone away already we
merged it getting back that later
there's a user changed so all the rights
goes through service person we have a
separate work of peeking of things from
working person and writing to the system
and then we have all the internal
changes to the catalog which we also
listen to and update our own cache
this is deployed to kubernetes
or we have an external varnish nginx
setup allowing us to use to strangle the
pattern when we break up our monolith it
hits our Web API ingress and then we
have a deployment for the Web API
Department we used to change the silo
host and then in each deployment you
sort of have the pods running doing the
actual work so we can have there just a
few above the eyes and then we have a
few silo hosts and scale those
separately
and deploying this is a little bit of a
history we have let's say we have worse
than 23 running all good and fine this
is comfortable and we want to have
version 24 so once we activate that
deployment in the clusters we activate
up in the same namespace in Cuban itis
and they connect to the other silos they
start getting production trunk traffic
that means that you might have worsen
one of something here and worse than to
overstate here so what elites loss is
that you if you change your interfaces
so need to sort of make sure that it
doesn't mix all the new data you worsen
the interfaces with an attribute and
then if a grain is activated here on
silo 3 and a request comes in from a
client which needs a new version or
leans will take it down it has a message
inbox which all these will keep activate
that grain and a new silo and complete
your request and that means that you can
do deployments without anyone noticing
so there will be you shouldn't really
notice what you can notice is that there
might be a bit more access on your data
layer on a database once it starts
unloading and loading grains again
another thing is that test you really
when you start putting things into
production you really want to be sure
that you don't want to roll back so we
have a problem now that we perhaps do a
bit more too much testing so we fail
something or we decide ok let's not roll
forward and we will roll backward and
then we will all the production traffic
we had on these silos will then how do
we move down to the old ones and it's a
not where doesn't feel right so we I
think we need to do more testing in a
pre-production environment and we need
to test it when both are running and we
need also to test it fairly well with
only the new one running so we need to
sort of in our pre-production or I mean
probably shut it down and take it up so
it only gets fresh state to see what
happens
because you're not really sure if when
you're talking to this one yeah I know
my data my user data will be on this one
but if it's using reference data or some
other data I have on that server you
can't really control unless you sort of
writing a plugin for it so deploying
this is is working well but it is not
something to be taken lightly
okay so another part of this is how is
this running when you start with all
ends there's a plug in for a dashboard
which I recommend this is not for our
operations people this is for the
developer we use it quite a lot it gives
you a good feeling of how the system is
running if doesn't take a long time
until you sort of get a feeling of how
these numbers should look it tells you
how many active actually grains you have
it tells you how many silos you have the
error rate if we go go beyond 0.01 or so
we there's a problem we have done
there's not a system basically it's if
we not done anything stupid in our code
that should be zero point zero zero and
then you have the response time and
requests per second and these are
internal requests between all the grains
so there will be a lot higher now right
behind you see that in in peak hours we
do about internally two thousand three
thousand requests per second while the
API is is doing significantly less than
that and you see it also the most cold
grain it would be our cashed our
stateless grains which are used by
everyone you can drill down into the
grains you can see a list of all the
grains so many activations you have the
throughput and latency for for them and
then you can also drill down into a
single grain and you get all the sort of
interface methods and how many calls
they have and the latency for each of
them it's very nice to have when you're
developing and get a get to know your
system we then also feed this data into
application insights so this is from
evening last week we do about a PSI
inside three million requests translate
to four requests per second so not much
about what we are extremely happy about
is the exceptions this is with
deployments and there's yeah not much to
say that we are extremely happy with
having that low number on the public API
and the response time is 29 milliseconds
also something we're happy about and
application in size is just a plug in we
have filtered it a bit to get not to get
too much data but something just add to
Orleans it has a lot of hooks for for
yeah storage for streams and queues for
analytics etc and this is other feature
we've implemented I don't know if we
were to the observer built and
distributed systems but it's basically
the same so we take the operation ID
application inside set on the.net coil
Web API request we add that
operationally into Orleans and then we
can enable logging so we get a full
insights in if I call this an external
endpoint I get the full list of
operations we're doing inside with all
the grains to see what's happening and
we've had to use that one or two times
to see we're doing something stupid
so lessons learned it's been very
different when you're not used actor and
start working with it very fun I think
we've benefited a bit from having or a
lot from having f sharp as a model it's
been very testable we do property based
testing and model-based testing so our
unit test coverage is a lot smaller than
what I'm used to
and also as I mentioned the fact that we
can talk about the model and reason
about without product owners and and a
new experience pent quite a high
performance and there's a lot of buttons
once you start doing these distributed
systems we had a problem with storage
the storage needs to be able to keep up
to speed with whatever you're doing you
can do that by shorting you can place
different kind of data and different
kind of storage and then we have life
cycle we shouldn't get back to and then
there's placement now when we have a
user and we want to we know that okay
for request I use it normally we load
quite a few grains if you can keep that
user on one separate server on one silo
it will save a lot of network and I all
latency so in Orleans you can either
write what's called a placement director
so you sort of write some code we could
perhaps use the user ID to say okay have
a static hash and put I use from the on
silo or you can use something which is
build in and say that okay I prefer that
all activations from this grain will be
activated on the same silo so that means
that we can we know that when a user
hits us we are normally just doing
memory operations
there's no sterilization
there's no network etc then you have
these cache cranes very useful makes it
really fast and nice so if you if you
have some shared data use it the model
not everything needs to be persisted you
can probably do something just in memory
while the grain is active and some in
state persisted storage like I said just
keeping track of the last thing you
watch will can save us a lot of
operations because you know we're not
going to have to change any sorts
because you still watching the same
thing so it will still be at the top of
your my content and then kubernetes yes
it is nice and shiny but nobody or not
that many are that good at running it
already or operating it there are some
but you don't necessarily find them and
then there's the number of silos so how
many how many service do we need to do
our traffic and basically there's just a
lot of things to turn on and it seemed
that if you okay we find one bottleneck
and let me get some more speed and then
you find a new one and so something you
have to work with an in keep track of
idempotency we all our write operations
are idempotent that has saved us when we
migrated four years of state from the
old solution for an arcade TV there's
about 40 50 gigabytes of data we needed
to import we had a bug luckily we had
our importances we can just run
everything and do the whole import fixed
for those 82 or 20,000 users which had a
problem just reinforce everything while
the other system was running and nobody
noticed except that okay they got their
missing favorites so very nice thing
happy that we did that didn't see coming
that clearly
and deadlock yes the grains are single
threaded
but that means also if you drink calls
back and forth you will and probably die
lurking yourself we have done that it
was not as easy as that one but sort of
a grain is doing one thing it
communicates with other why I'm
messaging and if you're doing one thing
from one grain it's busy and sort of end
up in that look possible yeah and then
we have this
we have learn about lot about how to run
kubernetes now not to run kubernetes we
were close to take out down the main
website because we needed to test our
migration we used all the memory on the
server there was no memory left to the
other applications cubanía started
killing things they did not kill us
first
so yeah it's a I think it's right for us
to run communities but it's still
something one need to think about then
yeah and this this was where we actually
kill things
so we have these position grains which
we know get a ping from the user every
30 seconds as long you are watching
something if it gets at the lab for more
than let's say a minute we know the user
is not watching anymore why should we
keep it in memory just from that
so with all liens taking care of the
life cycle you have to think of how long
should a grain be allowed to live in
memory I think we had about eight
million grains in memory and we're doing
the import and then things went bad and
then is ok let's let's add just a
lifetime some things you might wonder
how longer let's say debate user
favorite entry points can live for a day
no problem perhaps a page for a username
for a day but not the positions and the
favorites so after we adjusted the life
time for those down to a few minutes we
could rerun the whole import we never
activated more than 1.7 million grains
and we did not destroy everything else
so adjusting life's like we can really
help on the memory and the speed of the
system
logging is a passion that can kill you
when you do these dependency tracing and
you do not sample you will have a lot of
data and we added sort of double the
daily volume we report to application
insights in just a few hours and then we
have some limits on application inside
so we started softening us and
everything went bad
first of all our system went slow
because we were just sending too much
data to application inside saturate in
the network and then yeah everything was
horrible it's so we needed to turn down
what we log we need to turn on sampling
and so what is worse was that we
actually walked by accident did
dependency tracing for all calls so all
the grain chains where log to
application insights so that killed us
pretty good and then there's this
concept of direct clients so I said
we're moving away from having the Web
API as a separate deployment in Cuban it
is we are moving it into the same
process as the Orleans silo host and
reason that is that the client does not
know where grain resides that is kept in
a grain reference static hash set with
buckets on each silo
so the normal where a grain lives which
server you need to talk to you need to
talk to server first and then you saw
get okay I want to talk to something
which is inside of three you call silo -
and then salad who doesn't have it the
points are like three and go and get it
and takes time so we I think it was last
week deploy to production where we host
our Web API together with the early in
silo and that normally reduces at least
one at work up the changes perhaps not
that clear on the graph but when you
look at the
average response times this was a very
nice thing for us and then finally we
have storage we started out with with
cosmos DB and that is very fine you can
scale cosmos to be you drag a slider you
pay a bit more you pay after a while
quite a bit more and and you get the
sort of this throughput you need what
happens is that cosmos V starts putting
up physical partitions and then all your
request units are short or just I think
that divided so equally amongst all
those partitions and that's fine for our
import it it made sense we could just
read through four years of data in a few
hours but when we wanted to scale down
again you have all these partitions
you're not getting rid of them because
you cannot control how cosmos DB scales
up and down the physical partitions and
now we certainly have a lot of physical
partitions because you need that you get
the throughput so when you reduce the
throughput you don't have enough for
partition so and then it is slightly
expensive so we went over to table
storage and what we do is that we have a
separate storage account for different
grain types so position which is what
we're absolutely recording the most of
will have a separate storage account so
we know the throughput we get for that
and then we have some other grains in
all the partitions and I think that
saves us one hundred thousand a year at
least so that is something to be aware
of to keep the storage up to speed
and now I feel I dumped a whole lot of
things on you questions yes
the question is if we do also feed data
to personalization from all the data
sources no this one is just for keeping
track of your content for
recommendations and machine learning etc
we use we use other setups for that yes
yeah so the question is okay we have
these grains that aggregate everything
and what happens if you get a request
for some new data which you do not
already have as yeah well then we have
service bus so we take a copy of the
messages and feed them off to to a
separate table so we can scan we also
when you have customers DB we can query
it but if not that is a problem in sort
of having and that's why I think you see
in when peoples are discussing actor
system that event sourcing is not that
uncommon that they build this around the
rent sourcing just to keep all the
events because then you can just replay
the events if not you need to be able to
query for it and will table storage will
have to scan it and the data in table
storage except for the partition key and
Roky will be binary encoded of course we
can binary decode it the open source we
know how that works but it's still a bit
of work so that is something to be to
spend some time on thinking about which
business requirements what do I need to
answer to do to the business
well yeah
yeah I think the question is how do we
feel about having the the business rules
spread all over or how do they actually
work I think first of all you have
someone business rule it is normally
sort of you will find one method
responsible for doing that so it's very
testable I think and we are also I think
it's fairly easy to change and reason
about what is different or what you need
to think of is that we cannot change
things back in time unless of course you
have an event log you can replay it but
so if you if you want to change the rule
from from when we move from ok you have
watched 50% of a show let's make the
favorite to you have watched 60% that
can only be done for new things so that
is but that's for our case that is
actually what we want we don't want to
change your sorting retrospectively so
but I think yeah it's a fairly I don't
feel it's a problem
well was that's all thank you
[Applause]